[Music]
yeah the Mohawk what is this avoid yeah
okay I love the music isn't best yeah
[Music]
this reminds you of Sonic or if I don't
one thing that throw a strike
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh the switch forms okay
triumph our marriage and what am I
supposed to do stupid volleyball Dominus
[Music]
it's my success final form
I'm trying oh oh delish and he's running
away fabulously you only got those two
next time Ashley sure here we go
we finally get to play No okay I'm
welcome Charlie Potter I don't know
that's not how you do pool that would
probably break your finger
where's this instrument it's me me
why would I grade my boy advance in
Mexico oh I'm good thank you
best game ever oh okay cool I'll do it
girl yeah do it do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
poor guy yeah
[Music]
it's favorable pens are stationary just
wait until the end patient it has to be
complete I don't want to ice cream on my
hamburger woman I think we're done for
today anyway hope you enjoyed watching
leave a like if you did bro see you
later yeah yeah do the wave what you go
oh oh yeah oh alright
Oh